you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest comm
and I am playing a 5-game so I cannot
lean on the increment let's go with d4
I've played a Knight c3 g3 systems maybe
too much so let's try this unfamiliar
territory basically already I think the
move here is you five and then Queen d3
hmm or I could play Bishop d3 oh my god
Bishop d3 you know it's a little simpler
approach I believe mm defend the night
or just capture I'm gonna go with the
capture and maybe now II five or just
get one more developing move in could
also just play Bishop d2 let's do this
this is an opportunity for me to just
keep my structure okay that's a that's
one of those half developing moves I
think now I'm really tempted to play
this let's go for it
a knight here I'm gonna go here avoid
the knight exchange and focusing on this
hole in the black position okay so
they're preserving their dark square
Bishop c4 seems right I do have some
loose pieces here let's just castle yet
another developing move in huh I still
do have this in mind hmm maybe I should
go in for this now
and then that way I could play Bishop
here to defend my e5 pawn I think this
is a convenient way to defend they
Castle kingside Knight d6 let's let's
come right out here and see what they do
so weakening I want to exchange dark
square Bishop sand then drop a knight in
here not quite sure how to make that
happen let's just start with this and
actually I could do this just talking
about this if they Castle it I'm just
winning a rook full rook are they gonna
resign here oh man and I don't know what
just happened here oh I guess they
forgot that they're clean was hit mm-hmm
well that was one of the quicker games
I've played sometime hmm okay let me go
back Wow let's see where was their
improvement let's see I think at this
point here this is one of those
sometimes I define some movses mmm it
may help to categorize certain movses
half-developed are fully developed and
this I kind of chalk up as a this Bishop
move here as a half developing move off
the back rank yes but beyond that it's
really not doing a whole lot I know I'm
doing similar in a way but this is with
a purpose in to maintain my Queen side
structure hmm just avoid the knight
exchange or as soon as as soon as I play
this move I'm basically looking at this
square here I'm looking to operate in
the weakest point in Black's camp right
here this is a hole on d5 so that's why
I'm going for avoiding the knight
exchange I see my knight as the superior
to blacks this night could be dislodged
quite easily with c4 whereas my knight
not so much if you're playing f5
well that's some serious concession for
the whole kingside structure so that's
why the bishop is dropping back this
would be a really really tough piece to
work around so that's why they maintain
the bishop there between c7 and I think
that this is just the right idea to give
that night a boot maybe even here I
wonder if there's an opportunity for
night b4
just seems a bit backward because I
don't even see this as helping black so
they're down a lot of a lot of time here
I have some space and some natural stuff
with this pawn on e5 robbing the King
Knight of his favorite square enough six
it allows for these moves like Queen g4
and Queen h5 so I don't know and I got a
boot this is a really good spot for my
bishop as we as we saw and now it's
tough I mean because going right into
this year you have all of these pieces
and the Fon contributing to an attack
I can already drop in here and I would
it's probably mate this is probably some
forced make or reading something very
high here if he's captured I mean the
dark squares are completely ruined here
and then my queen sneaks in and I'm not
quite sure how you defend against that
so I think maybe the improvement and
we'll just have a very quick look with
the computer on this one but I think
after this capture and Bishop d2 the
better move here is to play e5 and this
is just a whole new ballgame because I'm
not getting an e5 for one I can't even
begin to start even thinking about
obtaining a piece on d6 the bishop is
free to come out to e6
um and this one pun really kills both
Bishop and Knight
you know I don't have these squares
available for the the pieces anymore so
this is this is really the improvement
and it's just a structural thing instead
of Bishop d7 just playing e5 and going
from here yeah as it was played out this
final position it's kind of just I mean
I guess from here you have to try
queenside castle I wouldn't say it's
losing here but it's definitely you know
I have some squares to be working with
Bishop c6 and this is already busted
pretty sure and it's just a double
attack against the Queen in the rook
um we'll just have a quick look I
believe it will be suggesting black
playing a five before I get an
opportunity to play e5 and we'll see
what more we could learn from this one
all right let's just have a quick look
here seeing what the computer suggests
for this line I could play e5 here but
Bishop d3 is another but let's just have
a quick look at this e5 move Knight d5
and then Bishop to d2 okay I think I was
pointing out night here and then Queen
d3 there's even this queen g4 stuff a
nun Knight takes Queen takes g7 pretty
sharp continuation white is a pawn plus
well evaluation plus one it's from a
Bishop d3 knight c6 is fine and then I
believe well I could already be playing
e5 but I played Bishop d2 and then this
is where so I could have make an
improvement right here instead of just
thinking about my structure I could just
get on with the 5 right here Knight d5
and then go in for a queen g4 very
thematic to have upon on e5 robbing that
King night of f6 and then playing queen
g4 this is a very sensitive point for
black suggesting King f8 not to even
think about touching this pond
weaknesses all over the place have 6 and
h6 and a bishop that is soon to pounce
on them so Bishop d2 and now after E 5
so tough 194 castles c4 queen g4 again I
just played Bishop there pawn and a half
advantage Queen g4 now and I played b3
is probably unnecessary but I was just
thinking a little bit about positional
stuff that is to just stop knight a4
from dislodging the bishop but there's
already direct stuff yeah I throw a
little bit of an advantage away I could
go straight in for Queen of four I guess
what's the idea with this supposed night
April night a 4 I could jump right in
with this same idea pinpointing f7 I see
so b3 was unnecessary I think there's a
an adjustment I can make with my
mentality here and that is in such an
open position these I don't know
soft moves like b3 the tidying up type
of moves could probably do without and
there's mmm
quite likely you know
a lot of Hamaker type moves that you
could pull off and Queen f4 is one of
them actually because 96 is pretty
pretty serious calling for f5 is best
you know
things says things have gone wrong if
you have to play f5 in this position
super weakening
so I could do without b3 Queen f4 was
better and after Bishop c6 Knight d6 is
really killing suggesting to take and
then just take here and that's what I
thought they would do cuz in the end at
least they're getting the bishop here
Bishop takes rook takes Bishop but the
attack continues this Knight is dead the
dark squares are dead and the King is
without a home
but has it played out they just ended up
I don't know missing that I was on the
Queen in the end okay one of the shorter
games but still some little
instructional points to take away from
this game this opening and as usual feel
free to leave any feedback in the
comment section below and I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye
you